wo fange ich an ich habe gestern ein
video hochgeladen in dem ich auf die
ersten videos von youtube an reagiert
habe welt generierten welt in minecraft
eure ersten jahr
es hörte sich so an als hätte ich eine
wäscheklammer auf meiner nase hat dieses
video hochgeladen habe es auch meinen
social media profilen geteilt und dann
war das eigentlich für mich erledigt ihr
event mitbekommen hat befinde ich mich
gerade mit meiner familie in österreich
im skiurlaub bis in den spann bisschen
mit der familie runterkommen und
sprechen bin ich hier nicht so häufig am
handy nicht so oft online das netz ist
auch einfach echt scheiße aber auf jeden
fall sagt dann beim mittagessen und das
video gegen glaube ich irgendwie um
12.30 online oder so und ich gucke dann
in meine mails irgendwann so ein zwei
stunden später und sehe auf einmal das
hier
ich habe einen claim bekommen der
urheberrechtsinhaber enthält entweder
einnahmen aus werbeanzeigen in seinen
videos oder statistische daten rund um
die aufruf zahlen für deine videos video
titel meine reaktion auf erste videos
von youtube anspruch erhoben von bibis
beauty palace als ich die mail gesehen
habe dachte ich mir erstmal hirn baby
bekommt jetzt alle einnahmen von meinem
video das klingt wäre das komplette
video ging ja auch über bibi dass das
ganze video ging gar nicht mehr baby
sondern tatsächlich nur 52 sekunden
krass und trotzdem bekommt jetzt alle
einnahmen vom ganzen video
menschenrechte sind sämtlich abstoßen
aber zurück zum ablauf der ganzen sache
wenn dein youtuber content anderer
künstler in seinen videos zeigten die
künstler sind damit nicht einverstanden
können sie entweder sagen hey das video
soll offline geschaltet werden also es
soll einfach nicht mehr verfügbar sein
oder die künstler bekommen einfach die
kompletten werbeeinnahmen die mit diesem
video generiert werde ich habe sogar
schon relativ häufig bekommen
beispielsweise sind meine
meistgeklickten videos videos wie ich
auf es gerd heidt
blechens reagiere oder nicht lachen
challenges die ja meistens über zwei
millionen aufrufe dafür die nicht immer
keinen einzigen cent ran weil die
unternehmen beziehungsweise kanäle die
diese kombination aus hochgeladen haben
die einnahmen für sich behalten das sehe
ich auch komplett ein weil mein ganzes
video von dieser sache handel zum
beispiel letztens of wrestling reagiert
da hatte wwe direkt auch nach zehn
sekunden gesagt hey das ist unser
content und wir verdienen daran das ist
ja vollkommen in ordnung aber zurück zum
thema auf jeden fall habe ich diese mail
bekommen und dachte zuerst das baby
wirklich mal video gesehen hat und
gesagt hat nehrig drückte auf den knopf
und mir können die ganzen einnahmen
dementsprechend habe ich dann einen
screenshot dieser mail auf twitter
veröffentlicht dazu geschrieben du bist
noch schlimmer als ich dachte ausbrüchen
außenseite eines babys beauty palace ich
denke dass man spätestens an dem
ausrufezeichen ausrufezeichen 1 erkennen
konnte dass das ganze von mir echt
ironisch gemeint war da habe ich halt
auch noch die screenshot bietet das ist
halt wirklich wegen 52 sekunden geklemmt
wurde ich meine freunde das video
gegenüber zehn minuten das heißt weniger
als 10 prozent des videos sind quasi
baby anteilig um trotzdem bekommen sie
die ganzen werbeeinnahmen da kein baby
an der stelle nichts für weil das ist
youtube und wenn auch nur drei sekunden
von einem künstler verwendet während der
künstler sagen hey das sind meine drei
sekunden dass geld mir dann verdient ja
auch wenn es ein stunden video ist alles
ja verdient einfach alles daran ihr
anhand der formulierung der spitze
bereits erkennen konnte war das ganze
eher oder gemeinden beispielsweise hat
man das eher an dem ausrufezeichen 1
gesehen und dann habe ich hatte noch auf
instagram dieses video hier
veröffentlicht in meinem heute
hochgeladenen video habe ich auf die
ersten videos von verschiedenen
deutschen youtube andrea geht unter
anderem auf 50 sekunden auf das erste
hochgeladene video von meiner lieblings
youtube darin die bi suite palace die
fans nicht gut und hat jetzt alle
werbeeinnahmen von dem video für sich
erhoben danke dafür
also wer die ironie und den witz sein
dann nicht versteht 30 abi hat es nicht
verstanden aber gut ich meine schaut
euch allein den text an den ich darunter
gepackt hat haye bringt denn dass ich
das wirklich ernst meinen und
abgepackten ich habe sogar noch als job
und haben ein video dann kommentiert
freunde ich heule wird 30.000 images die
voller tränen sind jeder kennt dieses
videos geht anbieten meine damen und
herrn ich verdiene kein geld mehr also
ich glaube wenn man ein paar
gehirnzellen
herausfinden können dass das ganze echt
mit einem lustigen hintergedanken
gemeint ist das war jetzt nicht böse
aber weiter wie es dann ab gelaufen ist
ich hab da noch ein video männer story
gepackt in dem ich gesagt habe ihr baby
morgen kommt eine ansage hier was soll
denn die scheiße hier mit werbung
erheben und dann war ich auf jeden fall
mit meiner familie essen und dachte von
baby kommt nichts mehr ich mache weiter
meinen content 78 weitergehen konnte
sie hat beim abendessen mit meiner
familie und in dem restaurant dort hat
man das beste netz in ganz europa
deutschland milchstraße auf jeden fall
sagt ich halte es mit meiner familie und
dann kamen die benachrichtigung rhein
von twitter wo allerdings nur die erste
zeile gezeigt wird und zwar stand dort
das ganze nennt sich content id und ist
ein automatischer prozess deshalb baby
haben nicht geschickt ich wollte darauf
legen die nicht weil das netz so
schlecht war ich habe dann noch drei
schon weiter gegessen werden nach
hofmann hotelzimmer gegangen mit den
ganzen twitter anzuschauen als ich
allerdings wirklich diese erste zeile
des tweets lesen konnte mit dem netz
unten beim abendessen habe ich mir
gedacht okay wie hat vielleicht wirklich
zugemacht content id auf diesen
automatisierten youtube prozess und das
wurde automatisch irgendwie ihr
zugewiesen und zweitens sie kann da
eigentlich gar nichts für ich habe ja
auch die stelle wo ich auch wie wir
reagiert haben relative uncut eigentlich
drin gelassen im schnitt in dem video
und dann dachte ich erst ok baby ja tut
mir leid alles cool
naja und dann bin ich halt auf hotels
mehr gehören wir den kompletten suite
durchgelesen das ganze nennt sich
content id und ist ein automatischer
prozess erst mal ich glaube es muss
automatisierter prozess heißen aber
alles gut mir wurde dieses programm von
youtube zur verfügung gestellt und mein
content zu schützen wieso sollte ich es
nicht nutzen um dein content zu schützen
greife ich dein content an oder war es
die wie ich will dich überhaupt nicht
angreifen
ich sehe das genauso wie du wenn jetzt
ein kanal ankommen würde und ein
komplettes erstes video sich runterladen
würden bei sich hochladen würde und
darauf werbeeinnahmen schalten und
könnte ich dich komplett verstehen und
stände wirklich mit dir auf einer seite
ich habe selber mal ein fall wo ganz
viele alte videos von mir runtergeladen
wurden auf einem russischen kanal
hochgeladen wurden und einfach mit
russischen untertiteln versetzt wurden
da habe ich natürlich auch die einen
dann für mich behalten weil da einfach
meine arbeit hochgeladen wird als
komplettes also das ist einfach da hat
er keinen eigenanteil dran allerdings
war auf den fall eines videos von
gestern zurück zu kommen baby da hab ich
wirklich 52 sekunden auf dein video
reagiert also das sind unter zehn
prozent des gesamten videos ich habe
länger auf julien bmw wie paletten milch
oder max reagiert als auf dein erstes
video natürlich werde meint dass es ein
automatisierter prozesse dann kannst du
dann natürlich nichts für dann tut es
mir an der stelle leiter sich da
angegangen bin aber also man hätte das
wenigstens zurückziehen können aber
jetzt kommt das absolute highlight ihres
tuns nichts wurde hier von mir manuell
geklemmt bilde die bitte nicht zu viel
ein alter als das gelesen habe ich habe
direkt antwort wieder raus gehauen wo
ich einfach nur gelacht habe ich echt
nicht was ich dazu sagen soll wo bilde
ich mir denn viel ein ich frage sie nur
warum sie gegen 52 sekunden ein
videoclip und das nicht zurückzieht aber
an der stelle baby eine entschuldigung
von mir es tut mir leid dass ich mir so
viel einbilden und wie ich es mir nehme
dich zu fragen warum wegen 52 sekunden
ein video geklemmt wird ich war nie
wirklich zum glück lädst du auf
instagram keine bilder hoch wieder und
irgendwelchen krassen pool skills wie du
im urlaub ist in irgendwelchen hotels
wie du in den eigenen whirlpool vor dem
aquarium in seinem hotelzimmer hast wie
du mit einem lamborghini durch amerika
fährst oder videobilder mit dir selbst
mit einer hand mit einem hologramm von
dir selbst hochlädt baby zum glück bist
du das und bodenständig und will es dir
nie was ein natürlich dadurch auch oft
bilder hoch wenn ich irgendwo im urlaub
bin oder irgendwie sowas aber wenn man
im glashaus sitzt sollte man nicht mit
steinen werfen baby habe jetzt erst mal
wieder zurück zum thema unter dem tweet
von bibi kamenz sehr sehr viele
antworten von verschiedenen twitter
usern die einerseits baby seite
verstanden haben andererseits auf meine
seite verstanden haben
und sich dort mehr oder weniger bekriegt
haben fast schon ich habe mir gestern
abend noch sehr viele antworten unter
diesen durchgelesen der hauptgrund von
babys community war ich soll sich
einfach in ruhe lassen und wenn sie das
claim will dann sollte das machen und
ich seine und blöder hater und der grund
der auf der gegenseite stand war
eigentlich prima lbb wenn du schon
längst und das wirklich noch mal dieser
prozesse ist warum siehst du den claim
dennoch nicht einfach zurück auf allen
dieser tweet das baby dann sogar ein
gegangen und hat gesagt hätte ich sogar
getan wenn man mich darum gebeten hätte
aber ich habe noch eine bessere idee man
könnte doch einfach videos produzieren
die nicht mein content beinhalten und
ein kurs miley du denkst echt es dreht
sich alles nur um dich in meinen letzten
20 videos habe ich zwei mal etwas von
dir drin gehabt und das waren keine
videos die komplett über dich gegen du
warst einfach nur ein teil in diesem
video du stand nicht im titel natürlich
hatte ich dich ins amt der du bist
deutschlands größte youtuber rinde
polarisiert ist komplett natürlich packe
ich dich in sydney bei dem einen video
habe ich ein spiel gespielt dass vier
bilder ein youtuber hieß und der teil wo
du wirklich in dem video zu sehen was
waren unter 30 sekunden das andere video
war man gestern hochgeladenes video wo
ich wirklich 42 sekunden auf dein erstes
video reagiert habe und ich habe dich
überhaupt nicht beleidigt ich habe er
sogar noch rewe oder paletten oder mich
selbst fertig gemacht als dich wie
versteht auf putze mein content besteht
teilweise einfach daraus dass sich auf
videos von youtube an reagiere oder mich
allgemeine der youtube szene beschäftige
und mein humor
na ja der ist halt so ein bisschen sag
ich mal nicht beleidigend aber so
ironisch gemeint und sarkastisch ich
würde euch gerne szenen aus dem
gestrigen video einblenden und wenn ich
wirklich böse gewesen wäre gegenüber
bibi und sie vielleicht länger als drei
minuten oder so in dem video erwähnt
hätte dann könnte ich es verstehen dass
sie gesagt hat okay ich lasse den claims
jutsu und ziehe den claim nicht zurück
allerdings habe ich wirklich nur gesagt
was man hätte negativ verstehen können
dass sie dich echt ganz schön verändert
hat seit ihrem ersten video aber das ist
nur positiv weil ihr erstes video ist
echt einfach scheiße um bei der meinung
bleibe ich wie ich habe mich noch nie
wirklich mit ihr unterhalten
was du für ein mensch bist ich gehe ich
ja auch nie als menschen sondern einfach
wirklich was du für ein content hoch ist
aber um zurück auf den ski zu sprechen
zu kommen sie hat gesagt sie hätte den
kleinen zurückgezogen wenn ich die nicht
darum gebeten hätte ja das stimmt da
muss ich an der stelle auch ein lenke
ich hätte einfach ihr schreiben könne
helfen kannst du vielleicht den claim
wegnehmen von dem die videos irgendwie
ein bisschen blöd gelaufen irgendwie hat
youtube das für sich erkannt tut mir
leid muss ich an der stelle wirklich
sagen hätte ich so klären können um die
ganze situation ist auch mein wenigen
sätzen zusammenzufassen ich habe gestern
ein video hochladen dem ich auf die
ersten videos von verschiedenen youtube
an reagiert habe unter anderem auf 52
sekunden auf das erste video von der
größten deutschen youtube die dispute
perle ist daraufhin habe ich eine mail
von youtube bekommen dass aufgrund der
52 sekunden einblendung von bibis video
nun alle werbeeinnahmen baby gehen
daraufhin habe ich auf twitter
geschrieben baby was soll das dann auch
schon mal als ich dachte
nimmst es ja auch noch die einlagen oder
was hat sich dadurch angegriffen gefühlt
und hat auf twitter gefragt was nicht
mehr dann ein bilden würde und warum ich
sie nicht einfach nicht gefragt habe ob
sie den kleinen unternehmen kann und sie
den claim dementsprechend darauf lässt
und weiter alles an die video verdienst
und da sind wir etwa eine damen und
herren bibel den claim mich zurückziehen
und will dass ich nicht weiter videos
über ihren content mache und ich bin
einfach nur ein dummer spaß ist auch
interessant was klingt dann dazu noch
wird bietet hatte und zwar jetzt mal
unabhängig von diesem fall wieso bekommt
man dann 100 prozent der werbeeinnahmen
wenn der videoausschnitt zum beispiel
nur zehn prozent des videos aus macht
habe ich in diesem video ja auch schon
mehrmals gesagt wie es anteil an meinem
video ist unter zehn prozent trotzdem
geht 100 prozent der werbeeinnahmen an
sie das ist nichts gegen die wieder kann
sie nichts mehr da kann ich nichts für
das ist eine youtube sache also ich
verstehe nicht warum baby da nicht
einfach nur zehn prozent der
werbeeinnahmen bekommt aber das ist ein
ganz anderes thema meine damen und
herren ich möchte jetzt allerdings etwas
ins leben rufen da ja gerade weihnachten
ist habe ich mir nämlich gedanken
gemacht baby wenn du wirklich den
kleinen nicht zurückziehen möchtest und
die einnahmen weiterhin alle an dich
gehen sollen ich weiß nicht ob das daran
liegt dass ich nicht nicht gefragt habe
aber das hatte anscheinend auch nicht
viel gebracht hat über vier stunden
später auf meine tweets dann reagiert
hast oder ob einfach das geld behalten
möchte ich weiß es nicht aber ich habe
eine spendenkampagne für dich erstellt
so sieht die ganze spenden website aus
und zwar spenden antibiotika es hallo
mein name ist luca ich habe in einem
zehn minuten 28 langen video exakt 52
sekunden auf das erste von babys beauty
palace hochgeladene youtube-video
reagiert daraufhin hat sich die youtuber
100 prozent der werbeeinnahmen
ich beanspruche daher sammeln wir
spenden für sie wenn ihr jetzt denkt
okay ja baby könnte echt ein bisschen
geld gebrauchen
dann findet ihr den link oben in der
beschreibung eingeblendet da könnt ihr
einfach draufklicken von einen kleinen
betrag an spenden falls nicht habe ich
euch auch in der beschreibung noch
unzählige weitere spendenkampagnen von
dieser website eingeblendet für dies
wirklich sinnvoller wäre geld zu spenden
man jetzt noch mal eine ganz kurze sache
hier direkt an die sbb oft ist es so
dass jetzt die leute sich dort anmelden
können und geldspenden können an dich
spenden an babys beauty palace man kann
dann allerdings da ich der urheber
beziehungsweise der gründer dieser
spendenkampagne bin kann ich wenn ich
den namen und die mailadresse einer
person habe eine einladung verschickt
diese mailadresse und wenn diese
personen über die mail dann die
einladung akzeptiert hat sie alleinigen
zugriff auf den kompletten geldbetrag
dieser spendenkampagne da habe ich da
ein bisschen informiert wie wir uns war
es ja allseits bekannt dass du bianca
heilige heißt er mit seiner website habe
ich einfach die business website von
deinem instagram profil genommen die
dispute palace at web.de und an diese
mailadresse habe ich dir eine einladung
zu dem geldbetrag dieser spendenkampagne
geschickt das heißt wenn jetzt ihr meine
community geld spendet an diese spenden
kampagne also spenden an die dispute
palace und bibi du hast zugriff auf
dieses geld dann kannst du dir entweder
auszahlen lassen und du hast das geld
dann musst du vielleicht eines meiner
nächsten videos nicht claim oder kann es
den kleinen zurückziehen oder weil
weihnachten ist könntest du das geld
eventuell spenden und alles wäre cool
ich will die räumlichkeiten strafen
belegen die man dann youtuber haben auf
dieser plattform ich bin einfach hier
meinen content zu machen und ich denke
die meisten leute wissen dass mein konto
und häufig daraus besteht dass ich nicht
nur gamestop oder irgendwelche lustigen
challenges machte sondern auch teilweise
auf videos von anderen youtube an
reagiere oder allgemeinen auf andere
youtuber reagiere oder spiele spiele wo
andere youtuber mit involviert sind und
ja der äußere ich mich oft beleidigen
dabei immer mit einem ironischen
sarkastischen humorvollen hintergrund
und anscheinend hast du das an der
stelle nicht so richtig verstanden ist
aber nicht schlimm habe ich wollte mich
an der stelle noch mal bei dir
entschuldigen wie dass sich die blöden
tweets rausgehauen habe dass ich mich
gefragt habe warum das ganze geplant wo
ich bedanke mich dass du mich darüber
informiert hat dass es ein automatischer
prozess ist also an der stelle
entschuldigung baby ich weiß dass gerade
weihnachten ist fest der liebe deswegen
hab ich kein bock auf wie ich glaube das
genauso wenig bock auf bfm deswegen
würde ich sagen wir legen das ganze ad
acta
aber wie ich weiß was das geschrieben
dass ich eventuell einfach keine videos
mehr über den content machen sollte
werde ich allerdings trotzdem machen
weil daraus besteht mein content und ich
hoffe du verstehst das ich nicht ich als
person angeht sondern nur dein content
und vielleicht können wir immer zusammen
was machen möchte von allen guten
geistern verlassen